I guess I don't nothing we can really do
about it now yeah and we're we're live
so like
yeah it is what it is oh geez don't like
how it's uneven that drives me [__]
Bonkers what's uneven the what do you
mean what's that even this is pointing
up because this is then point this down
oh
this is [__] gonna bother the [__]
out of me can I do it please no
God damn
you know I hear you right yeah I know
they can hear me that's fine just making
sure
this is this oh my God
dude what no can I yeah yeah okay cool
damn
okay
yeah
holy [__]
get the [__] kidding me
you want something else to put this on
then holy [__] nuts
leave it
leave it I was trying to see if I can
find something more statement leave it
oh my God why does it make you so angry
technology makes me so [__] mad dude
like what's going on here
uh
[Music]
oh lady [__] sticks
what the [__] is going on
oh my [__] god
that I'm
ah
let's start over
okay
I think
holy [__]
nothing
bothers you see how it's [__] crooked
yeah but also we're not posting it if it
were we we're crooked okay then do you
want to pick out pick up the computer
hold it talk to everybody and I will
find something that is more even
to put under it
technology bothers the [__] out of me
this isn't even technology at this point
it's just an angle
ah my God
this is say I'm going to jail soon so
thanks for the what
why are you going to jail man
well he looks like he's dressed as uh
so many different Pirates of the
Caribbean or not so maybe it's just
maybe it's for the dreads
this is hilarious you know what's crazy
Daddy I'll tell you something
thank you I I
I
come from
I guess I just want it to be
perfect
and it doesn't have to be
but it bothers the [__] out of me
is is technology the thing that Bala
gets me the angriest the quickest yes
yes it is I mean like we were driving we
drove from Grand Rapids here to Royal
Oak and when we got here my dad was
looking for oh no sorry we were in Grand
Rapids he was looking for our hotel and
he's looking on the navigation system
to try and tell them where the hotel is
but his locations just may not have been
working because it still thought he was
in Chicago which is where our layover
was
so he's searching at where our hotel is
and he's like why does it say that it's
230 miles away and he just goes on this
crazy old man around about how angry he
is about how stupid technology is about
how it's not working and why it
frustrates you so much and then I just
pulled it up on my phone and was like
great we're eight minutes away I was
like how did you do that I just used my
phone
well let me tell you what's bothering me
right now the fact that we look like
we're on a boat that's sinking because
it's tilting this way in this light and
what whatever hey look I had it at a
good angle but you didn't like it
because it was angled well I
we weren't straight ahead to the camera
we were straight ahead we were just in a
corner it was still straight on the
camera yeah but you said quote I don't
care about the light it's just a lie
yeah
I
I take it back yeah because we do look
like we're on a sinking boat
do you know what I mean kind of like a
yo ho ho uh Iceberg straight ahead is
right okay so listen I don't know I
don't look tilted on the video perfect
so here's what we're gonna do guys as
usual here on the stream
um I'm gonna copy the link for you guys
to join us
um we are here in uh Royal Oak Michigan
sold out weekend yeah
um and so
we're excited to uh be here last night's
show was a ton of fun
um can before we get started can I tell
you guys what happened last night this
and I've been traveling
how many years
20. what's up from Belgium
um okay
I order ubereats for me Jacob and uh the
guy who's with us again Snodgrass come
to Las Vegas I'm there every Monday
night I have a show every Monday night
at Kimball's Comedy Club I have a show
um so we order from Morton's Steakhouse
which is not it's a chain this is one
we've seen them a lot and also it's not
a cheap
Steakhouse it's like a legit Steakhouse
yeah
and so
they sent we order a rib eye a filet and
Jack orders a New York strip
they sent a rib eye a filet
and then Jack they sent two
on when I say uncooked not even
unwrapped still in the individual
package sealed
uncooked steaks I don't get the thought
process behind that like it definitely
is a first like that's never happened
before usually if they don't have
something that's in like if you order
something and it's not there they'll
give you something else like they did
but usually it's cooked
not usually it's cooked when you order
from a restaurant
you're not I'm not ordering from a
grocery store the reason I ordered from
a restaurant is because I don't want to
cook
who sends out two
uncooked steaks it was decree like in
Mortons if you guys know anybody at
Morton's
figure it out how would you how could
you how does that get past
I also don't get the thought process hey
you want to cook food tough [__] here's
some uncooked food like no not too not
too rare Corey like legit raw like it
was it was completely uncooked again it
was still in the plastic packaging that
they get it in like it it's not that it
was too undercooked it legit was not
cooked right if you buy it from like one
of those meat places it's like sealed
it's cooked it's an uncooked piece of
meat yeah exactly Katrina they had one
job and at the restaurant the one job is
to cook your food yeah and we like
Mortons too like we've ordered from
Mortons before good steak because we
like their food yeah dude but this
wasn't even like rare this was no they
didn't give an explanation they just
sent they just sent it
we also
no utensils like you sent me my food
even my cooked food you said in my
cooked food with no way to eat it here's
the thing too like
people last night were like well you did
you take the tip away from the driver
the driver not the driver's fault he
just takes what's in the back yeah and
there's also like I always I was
thinking maybe we could have gotten the
wrong order there's no way that someone
had an identical order to us and instead
of a New York strip it was two uncooked
steaks and yes full price and Mike the
fact that it wasn't just uncooked meat
it was non-cooked meat yeah we gave away
two uncooked steaks in the crowd last
night yeah it is so crazy let's not talk
about that
um but it's so crazy
that there was
uncooked meat being delivered
to us
from a restaurant yeah
I've never I've never seen
and they the funny thing is they put it
into go containers yeah
it was a really interesting experience
like I don't
I I don't understand can we can we get
this guy out of the in chat please yeah
yeah yeah yeah thank you okay
thank you yeah
um uh just
just so you know
uh
we probably won't acknowledge even the
douchey comments we'll just block it
yeah yeah we're not you know what I mean
um but it was really
crazy to me anyways
um I I hope that is the first and the
last time that happens yeah I ended up
eating the steak that they cooked for me
I I I I I had to give Jackson of mine I
didn't order a bigger steak I had just
like an eight ounce so it was a little
smaller but I felt bad that he ordered a
steak and didn't get one so I gave him I
gave him like half a month well that was
nice it seems like it was only right
yeah that was really nice yeah I did not
do that did you call the restaurant in
question
well here's the thing
by the time I got off stage and all that
the restaurant was closed and so I don't
know what the repercussion is but I I
would like to get my I would like you to
get your money back like for the whole
order why are you sending to me why are
you sending us two uncooked steaks we
didn't take any pictures of them did we
no yeah all right well then we're [__]
you know what I mean I think we're
[__] I guess that's true anyways guys
what a great trip so far Grand Rapids uh
last night
um no no we were in Royal Oak last night
Grand Rapids on Wednesday
it's Friday
right all right Grand Rapids Wednesday
yeah by the way yeah Grand Rapids crowd
might have been
one of the best crowds we've ever had
they were loud they were fun but they
were also like loud fun but also very
respectful which is really nice yeah
they were really into the show like
really really into the show it was
pretty crazy hey Vicky yeah so we really
had a good time
um you've been drunk enough to eat to
raw steak holy [__] right Lynn me too
I've worked in the restaurant business
if you count comedies food beverage my
whole life
sending out a complete raw steak is the
craziest [__] thing I've ever heard I
just the thought process doesn't even
make any sense to me no I'm sorry we
can't give you the cook steak that you
want so the next time you want steak
instead of ordering it we'll send you
two pieces of uncooked steaks so you can
cook it yourself who puts it in the
to-go container yeah it made me think
like we had more food but there wasn't
food that I could eat right there like
it who puts it it's like sending out if
I ordered broccoli it's like sending out
some seeds and being like here just
plant it you're gonna get some broccoli
eventually just not tonight yeah do you
know what I mean like it's the most
ridiculous thing
um but yeah so here's here's what we
want to some bougie restaurant well so
I've heard of that I've heard you can
actually buy
like like it's not the same thing but
when I worked at Jersey Mike's you could
come in and buy just a loaf of bread
from us like we could you we could sell
you the bread right yeah so I understand
being able to go to a restaurant and be
like oh I like this steak so much I want
to cook it myself yeah can I buy a piece
of meat like I understand that we didn't
order a piece of ramen there's a place
in La that I like I think it's called
Gwen where there's a butcher shop and
the restaurant right but this is not
what you do on ubereats
at Morton's that's not the deal you know
yeah like I get remember when we were in
Australia and we went to that place
where we get to pick the steak that we
wanted out of their little butcher
container and then they cooked it for us
yeah like that I kind of get no sense to
what happened last night will you be
taking photos with fans tomorrow yeah we
do meet and greets after every show yep
we do not charge for our meet and greets
um and I also really try to keep my the
ticket prices around
pretty affordable obviously closer is
more expensive but I'm not trying to
price anybody out
of my shows right and um we're taking a
picture with everybody oh yeah anybody
who wants one anybody who wants me you
just gotta wait in the line and so if
you're willing to wait in the line you
can have a picture with
uh with us or or just me or just him
some people feel bad when they're like
there was a young lady the other night
and her mom
and uh the lady was like I was like hey
come in for a picture and she was like
the young lady was like my mom just
really wants a picture with Jacob I'm
like okay cougar let's get in there
around I had no problem with that did
you see that comment somebody else no
I once ordered a curbside pickup of a
burger and fries drove myself home
unloaded all the other crap I had my car
opened the package and the burger was
missing from the burger part
wait so you got all the fun you got a
bun with toppings and no Burger
bun no meat that is
um High School yeah hilarious
um what's affordable that's a great
question I guess compared to
the other people that do what I do I
think I keep it affordable I I
affordable meaning
comparatively is Affordable I don't know
what you can afford or not that's a good
point
uh where is the meet and greet you're
gonna have to [__] figure that out by
yourself when you get there
you know what I mean I'm assuming since
you're coming you're at least semi-grown
up you're probably gonna have to listen
and read a sign or two yeah
um there's I'm probably not kind of
where's the meet and greet you're gonna
have to [__] figure that part out
yourself
holy [__] nuts
I wonder if they thought it was like a
public meet and greet like in the middle
of the city like that's why I wonder if
they thought it was that kind of thing
and not a meet and read after the ship
oh oh God again yeah yeah that happened
to me four Burgers no meat holy [__]
that is crazy talk
um all right listen guys so here's what
we're gonna do
um we're definitely going to oh yeah 20
and 16 year old bought you tickets it's
nice so we're gonna take questions from
you guys
um and just remind you that
so starting in I believe June
might be July I haven't decided yet
um the live streams will be on YouTube
and they'll be part of
a dollar 99 membership that's it 1.99
gets you live streams all month
sometimes Jacob will join me sometimes
it'll be just me
um on those live streams you can ask
questions I'll bring you on screen I'm
gonna be trying a lot of jokes and
stories it'll be like a workshop so you
guys will hear everything first at 1.99
a month
um and so
I I really want to engage yeah with that
community over there and so I really um
are your other children as funny as
Jacob
yeah man
he has to give you the dad answer I'm
gonna give you the sibling answer
uh listen
first of all your sister is really funny
funny dude Caitlyn is super funny yeah
your sister is real fun both of them are
no I'm not saying that they're not
they're all funny in different ways just
not as funny as me
that's okay here's one thing that you
have over them
in the funny Department
you're funny in different ways you're
you know how to bother me in ways that
they don't
like there are certain that bothers me
just because your breath is real bad
that noise bothers the [__] out of me I
I don't like the chewing noise
he hates it he eats a slurping noise too
like so if we ever eat something in the
house that's specifically I like that
okay pause so that whole sentence was
gonna be bad but you know what I mean
it's hilarious
the dumb one pays off like a slot
machine though and Slots are the only
way I gamble because they're the most
fun so that makes sense
but uh what was I talking about before I
got the sold that I forgot isn't that
that's not insulted I was just yeah
I'll forgot what I was talking about
do any of my other kids indulge in
cannabis
not like this guy no not like me
I'm not like this guy no yeah listen
they're right and by the way
um
does he I hate the ah after a long chug
of Pepsi
well I hate the long chug of Pepsi I
don't mind the eye yeah I was gonna say
I even don't like the long chunk of
Pepsi if you said Coca-Cola it'd be
different but this is right though his
humor straight off the cuff would it you
are witty Man true true
dad and I listen I will tell you
something else I respect the fact
that you do things to bother me it's how
I grew up because you did things to
bother me girl yeah man like there's no
doubt about it can I tell you by the way
guys tell me what you think about this
okay
so what I don't know if you saw this
yesterday I posted on Facebook and
Instagram I took a picture of him
sleeping and then I put a bunch of
filters behind it like I put them in
outer space and I put him in a horror
movie so I'm gonna start taking pictures
of him and like putting in an animation
and putting it on movie posters because
that [__] makes me laugh right yeah I uh
I've started doing a couple things to
him as well but it's mainly the scaring
because my dad would get scared does
some obnoxious things so I have a good a
good video of a bunch of those so
that'll be fun yeah I'm keeping that we
enjoy Tempe and thank you favorite
living comedian oh take that 100 we'll
see you hopefully in Tempe on New Year's
again
um Ray Ray said those pictures were
hilarious right I think a Photoshop was
funny but I think and Becky says just
waiting for Jacob's payback I think
Jacob's payback is going to be take the
form of scaring me
oh yeah all right here's the link again
by the way for anybody who wants to okay
so we'll start answering some questions
um and let's start with this
which comedians have been the most
influential both dead and alive
um that's gonna be more of a question
for you because this is still so new to
me yeah
and for me the only comedy I really grew
up around was his
I branched out like I branched out and
watched other Comics
um
but none that I enjoyed as much somebody
said you're gonna pick my nursing home I
don't think it's gonna be him my
daughter's gonna do all that stuff nah
you think this dude's gonna wipe
somebody's ass not my job I'll pick the
nursing home that has
you know no visitation
it sounds more like a looney home it
sounds like a jail what do you mean no
visitation what place has no visitation
jail even has visits yeah what are you
talking about
well you because you don't want to come
visit me I just don't want to take care
of you well you already put me in the
home you don't got to take care of me
once I'm in the home I'll probably put
Kate down as the emergency contact
this I have no doubt that Caitlyn will
be involved Caitlyn my daughter she will
be the one who picks out the nursing
home she will be the one who comes and
helps me uh and she will be the one in
the will let's be honest
we'll see about that
well we'll see about that how are you
gonna not do one of the any of the ass
wiping because you know what I'll be
able to do is in the time of old age
which is I know now but later on down in
your old age when your brain starts to
go a little bit I'll tell you you know
I'll write something up and make your
own new will and have you sign it like
it's you know like a dementia kicks and
I'll be like Dad I'm going to a school
field trip will you send this and then
I'll just have you sign a different will
that I put together yeah
um you know what I'm saying yeah dude
it's gonna be some like Knives Out kind
of [__]
yeah listen yeah I will tell you I'm not
I'm not um
I'm not too concerned with
if
someone's gonna take care of me when I'm
in a nursing home because I think your
sister will handle that but I am
concerned about the types of jokes that
you might try to play on me when I'm in
the nursing home no because I think when
you're in the nursing home it's it's
unfair advantage
you know what I'm saying like it's it
would be it's an unfair playing field
for me to come in and and torture you
with your old age right now you're still
you know competent and here with us so
thank you yeah you're welcome but so
that's my time to [__] with you but when
you're no longer competent it just seems
like an unfair advantage and also it
doesn't seem like it's as fun because
you won't know what's happened
really good point you know it takes away
a lot of the fun because I won't get the
reaction I want I feel like it'll be
more of a sad reaction if I try to play
a prank on you I mean and this by the
way is not the most terrible telling of
your schemes doesn't sound like the best
idea
that's what you think
yeah I mean I and honestly if I'm being
completely honest with you
probably not gonna remember he won't
remember about them all yeah he'll
disappear
um okay let's get to some questions
somebody said at least I have a standard
what's the most rooms you've done
cool
at one time
yeah I mean
I'm assuming I've done like four grams
at once
thank you
um I've done more acid though at one
point yeah one time listen are you ready
for the shroom show tonight Josh I'm
still looking for shrooms Micah
I'm still looking yeah so
if any you know anybody's got some I'm
still looking what's going on Jake
this is right here oh AJ
Are any are any of the other kids going
to join my Act yeah they do uh Caitlyn
doesn't want to hop on stage with me so
much although she did come on stage and
sing a song with me in Vegas my son
Trevor will be joining me in Dallas for
Fort Worth so yeah yeah this is a great
question I would love to know the answer
to this
what's the highest you've been at school
the highest I've been at school
all right so well I got I got do you
need them this weekend
yes he does
um before
okay so the one I can think about for
sure I it was it was grad night
and so it doesn't really count for
schools this is one that's this is
definitely the highest I've been on a
camp my school campus and then I'll give
you the highest I've ever been like
actually for a day of school
I it was grad night but you know it's
like they make you get to school at like
8 A.M and then they drive you to your
like Disneyland is where mine was so
they drove me to Disneyland for grad
night at like 8 45 in the morning and we
were there from like 8 45 to midnight it
was a long ass day
but I got we left at 8 45 I got to
school at 7 15. and me and I bought my
bong with me because I drove the car
because you were out of town so I
brought my blog with me to school
I brought two joints and I brought
Edibles so you took bong ribs at school
in that big ass [__] bong
yeah brother you keep it in the you take
it out of the bag well look again
we're in the car you just blowing out
the window and then you put it back in
the back right so it was pretty easy
actually and it was also the most
inconspicuous way to do it because a
blunt is it gives you away you know what
I'm saying like you see people passing
it back and forth but if you're just
sitting in the car and you know every 10
minutes or so is the cloud of smoke goes
out of the car and then you don't see
anything else after that
it was always like uh you know
misconstrued and people were like nah
they're all right they're fine but so
before school we had about an hour and a
half before we left and now keep this in
mind I would have brought Edibles to
grab nut because that seems like the way
easy way to do it yeah yeah yeah yeah
the senior class prior to me
[__] us because they brought Edibles
to grad night right which is fine but it
was a brownie like it looked like a
regular brownie they were so stupid that
they went into the bathroom to all share
a brownie yes instead of just eating it
while walking around yeah that's done
and there was an undercover Disney cop
in the bathroom who saw them eating it
and arrested all four of them and so
before we left for grad night they had a
drug dog at our school sniffing our
stuff to make sure we didn't bring
anything yeah so I had to get as high as
possible at eight in the morning
and make it last for as long as possible
so I we all there was like four or five
of us we all shared a couple joints real
bong ribs and then right before I saw
that dog I popped the quad dose chibachi
before I got on the bus
I was high for a long time yeah I guess
but not all day I was really tired
around 4pm I think I took a nap on a
Disneyland bench you know my grad night
we had like you know the senior party
yep and
um
I
I don't know about you guys but like I
used to steal booze from my parents
you know Liquor Cabinet you know Slow
Blues for me once and I would put like a
little bit of this a little bit of that
all in a mason jar you would just mix
liquor yeah dude I I couldn't get like
nine mason jars out of the house
so but it was like
it would be like every little I took a
little bit out of every bottle they had
that dude it was but you know what like
this oh I know you're spoiled dude you
you no that just that just doesn't even
sound like an idea I would even come up
with because it sounds terrible I want
to tell you something right now I
guarantee you I'm not the only person
that did that growing up
I guarantee you I'm not Robbie's waving
at you like he did do it Robbie yeah
Robbie knows man uh see Crystal did the
same thing trash can party yeah someone
called it swamp juice cup concoction
yeah all that stuff man we mix liquor
this is it man that's it
yeah
they did that too in Scotland yeah it
was so gross but it when you were in
high school you didn't give a [__] if it
was gross you just wanted to be [__]
up
that's it like you you I'd rather be
sober than do that no dude that was not
we were just in it to be [__] up
do you know it doesn't sound it doesn't
even that sounds like two that sounds
like an adios [__] on steroids
but by the way this dude went to high
school with me read what he said we did
it to see your shows in high school
yeah okay hey Martin I'm assuming I'm
gonna see you tonight man
uh yeah dude Jesus Juice liquid
desperation yeah this is all or liquid
death yeah this is all I did it too
by the way yeah the beer and putting
beer in the hard liquor we
we definitely tried that one time but
this this person I bet you read that
I bet you that person is close to your
age yeah right because he's also like me
who can't spell so I I bet you that
person is close to your age right yeah
and so they are like this is but jungle
juice was no joke yeah we [__] can I
tell you one time I I I put uh mixed all
this booze in a um
in a mason jar
and I put a little orange juice in there
right to uh
make taste better and then
my plans get canceled so I just put it
in the closet right
and it was probably in the closet I
would say for I don't know had to be a
week or two
and so
I'm a young guy I'm I'm not thinking
that the orange juice is gonna go bad or
anything like that oh
so I go to pick up this girl on the back
of my moped
and uh and by the way this wasn't a
moment he had to Pedal it first
right so so like I would pedal it and
ride around and then the then it would
start out you had to Pedal it you've
never seen that but people my age you
guys know what I'm talking a pedal
startup moped could they get any worse
thank you thank you thank you okay okay
yeah I remember the original four logo
Mad Dog a hundred percent too okay
so a hundred percent we should have had
some permanent damage from alcohol
poisoning in our generation with the
[__] that we were doing yes but so I get
on my
and I get this
concoction in the [__] uh-huh and we
crack it open and it makes it
which is not a good sign that means
there's something bad in there when we
smelled it I was like oh it's just
because of the alcohol that's why it
smells so bad so my date took a couple
real big drinks you know and I was like
I'm gonna wait to have any before I get
off the moped you know
and so yo
yo we we went over some real bumpy she
threw up on the back of my neck about 10
minutes into the moped ride dude just a
straight between the orange juice and
the bumps she went straight
right on the back of my neck listen I'm
gonna tell you something right now
a couple things you need to know I
did not see any boobies that night
no you did not nope but I'm gonna tell
you something else I was not anti I was
like hey I don't mind if I throw up on
me I would still be into seeing your
boobs and she was like take me uh home
yeah yeah that's the difference between
a guy in high school and a girl in high
school the guy in high school was like
vomit not a deal breaker for me
right as long as I might see boobies
what because yeah yeah dude boy you
listen uh uh we were a little more
desperate maybe
yeah that that sounds about right a
little more desperate I think but I
think also dude I don't think
I think you were
in high school you had more
girlfriends and just girls who liked you
than I did
I was definitely
our lip guy when I was in high school
and middle school I got dumped a lot
though
um and then but yeah but for most of
high school
I was in like a two and a half year
relationship
yeah and then the years before that I
was also in other relationships so it
just never uh
yeah but I don't think I don't think I'd
ever be that desperate
um okay I was can I tell you something
else nice to meet you Mary can I tell
you another funny story so one time I
was in Cape Cod
and my buddy Pat salford's house
and Pat Southwick okay and again just in
case we can you know just in case he
sees it yeah yeah there's no way Pat is
on Facebook or any other social media
okay but
um so hey from England we're going to be
at the UK in October
um and so yeah coming to Florida
August June and June and August first
weekend in June in Miami and then August
in Orlando what is this what's that John
putting up there looks like a drawing of
us I like that John we're gonna we're
gonna get to everybody down below here
in just a second
I forgot what I was talking about
Cape Cod oh Pat Southwick so this is the
dude
so we meet these two girls in the beach
we're in high school
and we go back to hey Ray Ray I love
that oh I love those gummies
um we come we we uh
we we go back to Pat's parents house
okay and this girl that I'm with named
her name is Beth believe it or not and
she didn't pronounce her ours she had
really bad breath so Pat started calling
her breath
so
he's and not to her face but he'd be
like how's breath doing I'm like God
damn dude it's so rough and so but I'm
in high school and I know for sure if I
can stick it out I'm gonna see a booby
and that's basically
what we're talking about you know right
so we get to Pat's house and I honestly
it's it's tough move I'm having such a
hard time
so we get into the kitchen and Pat goes
upstairs with the girl that he picked on
and I'm in the kitchen with breath
laughs and you know what I uh I go I'm
trying to try to beat the breath and not
be offensive I'm not I don't want to
offer admit you know unless you want to
get one out for yourself and then be
like you won't yeah but that still seems
to me so you know what I did is I got
out a jar of peanut butter and I took a
scoop and I I was like I love peanut
butter you want
you want to taste some people have some
peanut butter and she was like
no I don't want anything but I'm like
you should have some peanut butter
because I think of peanut butter breath
it's like thick so I thought maybe it
would soak up all the yuck in her mouth
probably just made it worse it well she
wouldn't
she wouldn't eat the peanut butter no
no she wouldn't eat peanut butter so you
never got to find out if it made it
worse or better I did not the only thing
she wanted was Doritos I'm like that's
not gonna help the situation
what you're you're going from bad you're
going from [__] bad to nuclear in
about half a second yeah yeah yeah
peanut butter breath way better than the
camel's [__] breath that she had I
like Doritos though so I don't blame her
I like Doritos too but that natural
flavor whatever the not the natural but
the regular one the nacho cheese that is
not so good for your month for your
breath they're delicious though they are
what's your favorite chip did we talk
about this favorite trip ever like
you're a Pringles dude yeah yeah yo yo
I'm telling you right now a sour cream
and onion Pringle is top [__] Notch
Robbie you're old shaking your head
you're just telling your age okay Robbie
you're right dude listen let me tell you
something right now the fact that you
think sour cream and onion Pringle is
better than Lay's sour cream and onion
lays or sour cream and onion ruffle is
the most insane thing I have ever heard
you say heads up
no dude it is you're saying the sour
cream and onion Pringle is better than
the sour cream onion lay yes
you're out of your [__] hey you know
what I don't have to worry about with
Pringles and I always have to worry
about lays that half of my bag is filled
with air when I get something from Lay's
okay dude
when I get something from a pringle box
okay a Pringle can that thing is filled
to the top all right there's no air in
that I was opened a Lay's chip bag and
there were four chips inside of it at
least they were four things that tasted
good no I didn't even I threw the bag
out listen dude that doesn't matter if
it's filled with [__]
I don't want I'd rather have a bag half
filled with tasty and then a bag full
filled with [__] Pringles better than
that that's our grand Pringles top tier
chip Lynn we're in
um
uh Portland every year we love that
Portland
let's just see what people are saying we
can also get the best breakfast flour
thank you that's not Jake for the win
Cody what are you talking about somebody
said Doritos Spicy Sweet Chili that
stuff is fire it's a new flavor salt and
vinegar Pringle yeah but none of it salt
and vinegar lays way better than the
salt and vinegar Pringles disagree I
feel like there's more flavor on the
Pringles than it is the lace but it's
not a chip still don't call it a chip
don't call it come back don't call it a
chip because there's no comeback for
Pringles Pringles but at the top of the
game for a while I would I would rather
open up that can and just see somebody
that did [__] nah
Pringles you're telling me that if it
was dire need and you needed food and I
handed you a can of Pringles and they
were [__] it you'd be more happy
than the actual print everybody's on
with you in the sour cream because
Pringles are gas that's why
thank you Jacob is wrong thank you so
much hey Hutch everybody can have their
opinions it's okay that yours is wrong
too
look at everybody saying you're wrong by
the way you just said everybody was on
my side and then just said everybody
said I was wrong yeah I know you've seen
like four of them Spicy Pickle Lays
yeah
have you ever done Molly I have he has
that no
I I just don't all right Josh as well
I didn't see that one I just I'm letting
it pass by
it's a crisp not a chip interesting no
no no no she's from England
oh chips or fries crisps are chips
wait wait wait wait wait what's this
Pringles read that ad on my glasses
Pringles or striped chips layers are
aerated I put the floors
in Frito-Lay and Pepsi
okay thank you sir
yeah but hello
thank you
look I just want to put it out there I
don't think Pringles are the best chip
of all time they're top tier but look
you think you're gonna tell me lays is
the best brand of chips I'm not saying
you are I'm saying damn
I can I tell you what I think my
favorite chip of all time is I need I
need brand and I need flavor all right
I'm gonna tell you I'll tell you the
brand name brand new flavor ruffle sour
cream and cheddar oh the orange ones
yeah those ones are pretty fire yo those
are so pretty good I'm not gonna lie I'm
not gonna lie uh for me like I'm a big
kettle cooked chip guy like I like that
when they're crunchy like those kettle
cooked jalapeno chips are Next Level
however
when I worked at Jersey Mike's for three
and a half years there was a brand of
chips that they sold that was not a
Frito-Lay company I don't remember
actually no it might have been lays
Affiliated but I can't remember it was
like a Maui sweet onion flavor oh I know
what you're talking about
yeah those are deep that's the best chip
is delicious all right guys we're gonna
open up the chat to questions
uh I am going to bring some people in
from uh who are down below uh if you
guys have any questions not if you have
any questions but we would love to hear
your question
um and here we go Robbie you were up
here first so let's start with you man
how you doing dude
hey what's going on gentlemen what's
going on by the way I got it I'm not
arguing about Pringles versus ladies I'm
just saying lasers better
yeah if there's no argument I'm with you
on that no argument but yeah laser
better now what's going on gentlemen
that's been a long time seeing you and
uh just wanted to jump on to see how
everyone's doing and uh quick question
or I want to say quick question but the
whole
story about being high in school so the
first time I got high at school
is I'm at that point I was paranoid so I
would like walk into the classroom and
everything school I was like probably
like 10 minutes late but I walk in and I
sit down and I just look around and I
could just tell that all eyes are on me
but even though the eyes weren't on me
but you can't you know get the idea that
paranois I just got up and left up room
without even saying anything and just
went home
I went to a Chicago public school that
didn't really care about our education
so I just left and yep went home
like for me my senior year I would
probably say 95 of the year I was high
what yeah yeah I I don't admit my
freshman year I flunked my whole
freshman year I had to make that up my
senior year I was a fifth year senior so
uh don't go ahead and blow all your
grades on freshman year if you have to
make it up fifth year senior but yeah I
graduated with a diploma anyways but
just wanted to say that
thanks Robbie guys have a good one hey
come to Chicago I need you guys to come
to Chicago soon man I need to see you
guys live I missed your last show a
couple years ago but you guys got to
come back to Chicago we'll be there this
year
I hope so I can't wait you guys have a
good one
I have been in Chicago is there a game
you like to play on a lot there's a lot
of games I like to play Stones I usually
just play video games snow in a period
um I feel like it heightens my senses
and I put that it doesn't but that's
what I feel like okay
um but it's fun like it also just you
know it's two of my favorite things
combined so I usually smoke weed to
relax and then I put my my headphones on
and play video games to escape the
outside world
so but I play uh FIFA I play Apex I play
rocket League uh not a fortnight grind
anymore because
it's sweaty
um what's sweaty it's a term for gaming
that like if you're playing people who
are like really sweaty it's like they're
tryhards
oh really yeah so it's like why are you
sweating so hard at this game or you're
such a sweat it needs you to try hard oh
[__] I had no idea yeah I know you did
you don't play video games yeah but you
don't want to be referred to as sweaty
yeah it's also it's also not
sweaty is like a backwards it's like a
it's like a compliment insult right like
they're calling you sweaty because
they're like why like just play the game
like a regular person but then also if
they call you sweaty it's like they know
you're better than they are so it's kind
of like yeah you know what I'm saying
yeah so
um Casey I was just in Chattanooga three
weeks ago
um all right let's see what other
questions we got that we can answer for
you guys I want to kind of try I want to
try and get him into play or not get him
into playing but I want to uh put him in
arcade Apex game or a fortnight game and
just see what happens
um Josh what would you do if you weren't
doing comedy do you know the answer to
this
owning a restaurant
no I honestly would be ah
I mean I thought I would do this just
listening to stories from teachers now
and dealing with kids and their parents
now it seems like a hassle you wanted to
be a teacher yeah
yeah yeah
interesting I like teaching people dude
and absolutely I would have
done it if they had allowed me to coach
a sports team a baseball team oh so like
you had you had to coach but then you
had to obviously teach something yeah
yeah yeah so would you be like the PE
teacher and then the baseball coach I
don't want to be PE teacher yeah maybe
I'll be people PE teacher's so easy you
put a bunch of dodgeballs on the
basketball court and you said all right
here's an hour Ready set go yeah man I I
I think
um
I like teaching people I like watching
young kids
get get it right you know what I mean
you like seeing the light bulb go off I
love it I love it I love it I love it I
love it and I love the idea of being of
service and I think teachers are way
underpaid and way underappreciated and I
think one of the reasons that people are
complaining about public schools because
who the [__] wants to be a teacher right
now look you got kids filming during the
class you can't say or do anything to
them without them disrespecting you or
without you being fired yeah you have
parents who take the kids side
automatically do you want to know what
my dad said
and my dad's been an educator since the
60s he was like you know the difference
is he said when we used to have a
parent-teacher conferences and if the
kid was getting a c
the parent and the teacher would look at
the kid and be like why are you getting
the C
nowadays when you go in the parents
attitude is why are you giving my kid a
c which is ridiculous nah man yeah it's
ridiculous and so there's no
accountability for the child from the
parent
so like it makes it really difficult to
for the teacher to do their job or to
try to discipline somebody you know you
saw what happened
to a teacher who took somebody's phone
oh she got smacked yeah dude and they
won't take a shot or you wouldn't get
tased or woman gets so like I I would
have said kid uh and Coach too
yo man I just couldn't deal with parents
I remember when I was coaching your
teams
I would tell the parents on my teams if
you're a screamer from the stands you
should probably switch teams right now
or stay home yeah you can encourage it
you can scream encouraging things but if
you're gonna scream at the umpires or
even scream [__] at your kids you're on
the wrong team you're on the wrong team
for me it's players play coaches coach
you know the umpires referee and the
parents you cheer yeah we played on way
too many sports I played on way too many
sports teams as a kid with that with one
parent just constantly constantly
screaming at the ref or screaming at the
code sure oh no we got Peppers pepper
spray that's right yeah you know what
I'm saying but those yeah those and
honestly I remember talking to those
kids on my team and I was like how's
that make you feel and they were like
I'm embarrassed as [__] yeah like that
my mom won't stop yelling at everybody
for nothing I'm like yeah I bet I'd be
embarrassed too
um we were just like we were just in
Australia
okay let's uh let's find somebody else
who wants to ask a quick question let's
go
what's up what's going on uh not much uh
it might not be a easy to answer
question but I know a little while ago
you were saying Josh that Jake didn't
want to follow in the footsteps of
trying to do comedy and just kind of be
more of like a stage presence or
performer of some kind besides that and
now it seems like you're taking on that
mantle of wanting to do comedy a little
bit more Jake and I'm just wondering
where did that shift that kind of change
of mind happen honestly it's a really
good question because you're right for a
long time because I had seen The Good
the Bad and the Ugly from Comedy it's it
wasn't something that I had generally
wanted to go into
however
I have since covid have learned to live
my life without closing any doors right
so when an opportunity comes my way and
a door opens I like to at least give
that opportunity a chance do you know
what I'm saying the honest effort yeah
yeah exactly and I was given that
opportunity when we were in uh Austin
Texas
um because
starting off this year that's exactly
what we stuck to was I wasn't doing Time
by myself and we were just doing the Q
and A's that you guys have seen clips
about
and then we were in Austin Texas and
they said hey so in your contract it
says your son's hosted and I was like
what
and they said yeah do you want to give
it a try and he looked at me and I said
sure and I think I found uh like it was
like a newfound Rush right like when I
got up there and I told a joke and
people laugh at those punch lines it I I
understand it it's it's addicting going
up there it was like something you
didn't know that you needed until you
got it exactly and so I just I I had had
that door closed for so long that when
that door opened and it gave me an
opportunity I just decided to to give it
a run and look who knows I I don't know
if this will turn in to what my
full-time career would be and if I you
know obviously he won't tour forever and
that's just you know a plain fact so if
this turns into me doing my own tour and
me doing my own hour and me doing my own
thing then great but also if it leads
somewhere else it was great to have the
opportunity you know what I'm saying
yeah absolutely and I Josh I just want
him to do
whatever makes him happy and so like
what I've found
is
I know what makes me happy I love I
obviously love doing
stand up and performing live or else I
wouldn't be doing it anymore and so like
it he'll have to find out if it's what
he loves
you know and that's all I want for any
of my kids it's just hopefully you get
to enjoy what you're doing because
they're very rare people
in this world it's very rare that people
do what they love for a living which is
a a bummer but like
so if this is what he digs I I you know
[__] yeah dare every step of the way
yeah man 100 absolutely
um I appreciate you asking that question
man I like your Freddy Krueger shirt
thank you I had uh I've had like three
or four iterations of the sweater now
one of them was all patched up with like
actually I had a Camp Crystal Lake patch
holding up one of the sleeves because
I've got a tear in it that's awesome
[__] yeah yeah wow all right Josh great
talking to you brother always a pleasure
much love stay safe stay beautiful
everyone take it easy now we'll see you
next week
um read that to me uh you seem to have
done a great job with Jake great job
great job with Jacob so do you have any
parenting advice for a newly single mom
who's trying to raise a smelly hormonal
six foot tall 14 year old boy well
listen
that does describe you too nah can I say
something though yeah not a lot you can
do about the smelly thing until he
starts to want to impress girls then
he'll figure out what a shower and
brushing his teeth is
that also you know what he used to tell
me all the time that really got me into
it especially the brushing the teeth you
know what he'd always say to me he goes
did you brush your teeth I go no he goes
you know what girls don't like yellow
teeth he would say that to me all the
time did it work oh yeah
can't blame him you know what I'm saying
it worked and then when when he starts
to be like his I remember 13 is like you
you kind of are attracted to girls but
you're not really sure about it this is
before high school he's gonna get to
high school and see what seniors look
like and he's gonna be like oh no [__]
but now I probably step my game up at 13
as a boy the testosterone is starting to
come out and whether you're whoever
you're attracted to
it starts to you just know I mean at 13
I'm sure some people aren't even sure
who they're attracted to but you just
know that your dick is is is starting to
rev up right and nobody wants the yellow
teeth yellow teeth partner
he'll figure it out definitely yeah I
will say this also Erica that's his
advice mine is this
they're dumb
dumb as [__] dumb I love your hey man
t-shirt Ray Ray
the 13 year old boy is one is one of the
dumbest creatures to walk the planet
Earth
so what I would tell you is this this is
really important do do not be somebody
who is constantly correcting them and
everything they do they're gonna [__] up
a lot
pick and choose
if you're the single parent that means
you're you're the one
also you want you want your 13 year old
to be able to come to you and if you're
constantly correcting them they're never
going to feel safe in coming to you
so pick and choose the things don't
sweat the small [__] pick and choose the
things you really need to hop in on and
be like hey don't do this or this isn't
right or but not every don't bust Every
Lie
uh it's strict parents what do they make
sneaky kids
I had a lot of those friends in high
school whose parents wouldn't let them
go do anything so what were they doing
every weekend when I was when we were
all hanging out sneaking out of the
house I don't know any of you went to
college with a Mormon but they lose
their [__] that first week of freshman
year they're like wait I can [__] do
absolutely everything so you know yeah
so syllabus week is where you find out
who's been cooped up their entire life
yeah for sure yeah yeah so like that's
it don't sweat the small stuff uh
you know and 13 no matter how tall and
by the way you're right don't forget six
feet tall is not a man
it's still 13 is just a [__] kid yeah
just a kid that's gonna [__] up doesn't
know
right doesn't know like just they're
gonna [__] up but the [__] up is not it
um
does not tell you does not define them
they have to make sure that they know
that too everybody [__] up man it's not
going to Define all right and what the
[__] honestly not the [__] is what
defines them what defines them is how
they decide to either better themselves
or get up from that [__] up yep and it's
it and it's always great to have a
parent there who or both parents but in
your case you who's there for your kid
at all times by the way you're right
preachers kids this is hilarious read
that just found out you're live
nobody I'd rather hear on the toilet at
work perfect dude I am honored that
we're very complicated with you 100 I
guarantee you that's not the only person
on the show I love that Lynn he's 26.
um
what was that what did I say I was whoa
what was that thought I was raised
Mormon starting ninth grade I was
Raising so much hell by the way you're
squinting at the screen you need glasses
like me no you said that font was
different did you see that font couldn't
tell what was going on okay all right
it's like a hipster font
um stand up all right anyway back yeah
any other uh if you have any other
questions in the chat well obviously
when are we coming to Alaska whenever
they book is there whenever it's not
cold yeah psych always cold
um all right let's say hello
to Ray Ray what's going on Ray Ray
oh so how was Run Dog
how is run dog with Indiana
Oh my god dude I've been waiting now
follow that guy on Instagram how great
right dude Indiana's just tongue yes I
didn't know I was like yo where'd all
that tongue come from what the by the
way for those of you don't know what
we're talking about this sounds a little
weird yeah okay that out of context hey
so run dog is a in Vegas it gets too hot
to walk the puppy outside
and so the guy comes over in a van and
he's got this treadmill and your dog
gets on it and goes [__] bananas
um it it was like
Indiana Jones our dog was going bananas
he loved it but I didn't know he had
that much time
dude dogs have
sometimes deep time that was deep time
in high school
uh yeah yeah
uh
yeah if you have a hard time adjusting
or did he just he just grasp it easy
that first time on the treadmill he was
a little iffy because you know it's not
a treadmill it's a treadmill they power
themselves yeah yeah yeah I saw him on
Instagram he's a good guy yeah I will
tell you this dude [__] went hard in
the paint that second run yeah my dog
who's on his hoodie wouldn't been able
to he would if it's not powered and it's
powered by him dude's laying down on it
he's not running anywhere
you can give me a treat or what yeah
he's got he's got long bottom small legs
he can only walk for about 10 minutes
before your dog is like this big dude
that's what I'm saying he gets tired
after 10 minutes of just walking
um somebody just said I'm gonna answer
this question Kelly somebody said I'm
still working on tonight but I can
definitely get you streams tomorrow
okay
uh Carpet Ride time listen Beggars can't
be choosers is it Katrina's birthday
today
if it is Katrina happy birthday but
anyway well I'm I just got an offer for
Denver so I'll let you know when it
comes up my God yes can't wait okay guys
this is a great question what are some
of the jobs you had before being comic
yo I have done
a lot
uh I've painted fire hydrants did you
really uh-huh I've laid concrete yeah
but you did that when you were a kid you
said yeah that's before comic oh I think
they mean like as an adult like what
jobs jobs did you have anything you've
ever done in the restaurant delivering
food catering waiting tables dancing
dressing up as Peter Pan riding a moped
yeah but that was a long time ago too
but I definitely entertained the
children's parties
um
I got uh
let me think my I did like I went to a
children's party once dressed as
Peter Pan
and um this woman had some sort of
Peter Pan fetish oh yeah dude she was it
was the woman whose party
the kids it was her son's party oh she
specifically requested Peter Pan yep
she wanted to be your Wendy dude she was
she was like do you mind to come
upstairs so I can pay you I'm like no I
think I know what that means I think I
know what that means yeah dude it was
that's right that's a hundred percent
right it was yeah we were in Never Never
Land for a little while for about 30
seconds yeah dude maybe 26. close enough
um and I'll try to give you the benefit
of the doubt yeah I was Captain Hook
thank you Christian gross yeah it was so
crazy uh but yeah
yeah that was like sending somebody up
to your room dressed as Mickey Mouse
oh I also did one as a clown and a woman
had a clown fetish ew yeah yeah I have a
clown fear
yeah this woman had a clown fetish the
guy so the guy who booked the party he
goes this was so funny he calls me he
goes hey I got a party for you I go cool
and he goes first of all can you do
balloon animals and I was like why and
he goes it pays 50 cash extra and I go
yeah I can do both
I couldn't do yeah well I have a feeling
I know what your one balloon animal was
I had a bunch of different balloon
animals
what what was yours no I know what yours
was and it was just blowing up the
balloon and saying it was a snake snake
worm stick
yeah but it was a shame
uh stick worm snake swords yup sword uh
pencil no I didn't do pencil good one
though
or
um but so I did and then this woman told
me uh
the guy who booked the party was like
she always books clowns and she only
books Tim but Tim's out of town
so you want to go over and do it and I
said sure he goes I'm gonna book you but
only under one condition I go what he
was you got to tell me what the party's
like because Tim won't tell me about the
party
and I was like oh I [__] definitely
want to do this one yeah
so I show up and Tim's not you know she
comes to the door she's like oh no Tim I
go no and she said and I was dressed
like a clown she looked at me and she
goes you cool like Tim I was like the
[__] coolest
hell yeah I don't know what that means
but yeah I'm cool like Tim
and something that sounds like a great
name for uh for the title of a song too
like Tim let me tell you something Tim
had himself Tim was getting paid extra
for keeping his mouth shut
he could pay for doing balloon animals
by the guy so it was 75 cash for the
party for me plus 50 for the for the an
hour okay okay 125 plus 50 for cash or
balloon animals well she tipped 300 cash
forgiving [__] just as long as you
were quiet wait wait so she paid you but
she was the one with the services yeah
seems like a pretty good deal what was
the most
uh but she only uh
listen
I could not keep from joking so she
didn't ask me back nah but she called
Tim back yeah I um apparently Tim was
cooler than you yeah because you know
what I did I sprayed her with my flower
uh she didn't think that was fun that's
pretty funny
is spider with your flower code for
something no okay I just want to make
sure yeah yeah but see that I gotta
clear that up I just want to make sure I
want you to know I want you to have any
bucket list places you two want to still
do comedy at Madison Square Garden no
um yeah [__] yeah I would do it anywhere
man
um no no no we're not anywhere but focus
in on the tell me what the give me an
answer to that question
I think The Comedy Store
in L.A yeah I think that would be super
cool for us to go because that's kind of
where not where you started but where it
was a lot of the beginning of your
career especially as like a single dad
in La
um so I think The Comedy Store will be a
cool full circle
um
for me it's TD Garden
of course Boston and we'd love to do a
TV Guide
um I would love to do some of the iconic
places Carnegie Hall
um I've done Radio City
I would love to do Red Rock oh yeah Red
Rocks definitely I [__] love to do
Red Rock uh Red Rock's definitely out
there but yeah I would love to do
Wembley
Wembley in the UK I would love to do the
O2
those are like I love that I love I love
that because Wembley and O2 are like 80
000 people I love it man listen you
listen they're not dreams if you can
attain them tomorrow
do you know what I mean they're not
dreams if they don't scare you a little
bit yep so that's what dreams are and so
I'm not
I'm not you know what I mean yeah
absolutely so this is what I wanted I
also love that you know what Wembley and
O2 are
I don't know if it's called O2 anymore
it's not called O2 anymore is it the the
football arena
well I think there's an O2 Arena and
then I think there's
we're just mixing it up because there's
a football team that called Arsenal that
used to be sponsored by O2 yeah but
their Stadium's called the Emirates but
I think there's an O2 Arena I think
you're right yeah let me just
do you see other people from my family
all the time you're just not paying
attention
my daughters on my Instagram and so is
my oldest son they just don't my
daughter and all the son don't live
near me and you but when they are around
me they're on my socials and my wife's
on there all the time yep so absolutely
yeah I'm gonna get some chips all right
go get some chapstick I'm gonna bring
somebody else on the screen
uh
do my kids still go to Petco they do not
I'm gonna bring somebody else a screen
Roy you got a question for us they say
Roy or Ray Ray sorry that says right it
works though you hear me Broadway
nothing much I do have a question though
it's a little bit of a bummer story but
I want to get into comedy okay and
a lot of comedians like Whitney comments
they say things like these younger kids
they want to go on stage and get free
therapy it seems like they don't care
about the jokes
and with my backstory I'm 21 years old I
am me and my uncle are the last living
family members with our last names I
watched a lot of people drop and I kind
of want to incorporate that into my
comedy
but I've seen a lot of people or a lot
of comedians specifically that don't
seem to like my generation doing that
listen first of all
when I say this with all due respect to
Whitney who I love
and all due respect to anybody who's
saying saying get off my lawn
who gives a [__]
good point you talk about what you want
to talk about and your Niche will find
you you know they're
there's a lot of opinions on what comedy
is and what comedy isn't I'm going to
use a great example of a woman named
Hannah Gatsby Gatsby I think that's her
last name
and she caught a lot of [__] her first
two specials
um because people were like oh that's
not stand up well whatever the [__] it
is there seems to be a large group of
people who like it so if it's not your
what you like then what you should do is
not listen to it
and if you do like it then listen to it
you know what [__] I get for playing
guitar at the end of my set oh my God
yeah and like so for me
for people who come to my shows
then they know what the deal is I do an
hour of stand up before I do guitar and
my guitar is really just a place to put
more punch lines it's just jokes people
get butt hurt and who gives a [__] dude
and so Ray the only way for you to to
do art in general whether you're
painting acting singing is to find what
makes your art uniquely you and if that
uniquely you is lost then talk about it
dude now sometimes that's harder to make
funny
there's no doubt about that but like and
I would say if you're just starting it's
going to be impossible to make fun
there's a certain skill set
but the only way to develop that skill
set dude is to start developing the
skill set I took a writing class once
and um
the instructor said something that made
total sense right up front
he was like hey your first 10 scripts
are going to be terrible so you better
start writing
and your first three years of Comedy
your jokes are going to eat dicks right
they're gonna be [__] terrible
you're not gonna know who you are how
you stand how you you're figuring all
that stuff out as you're figuring out
how to tell jokes so
you should joke about what you want to
joke about dude and if you want to use
it as therapy use it as therapy that's
honest
that's all we can ask for
pretty much sure yeah I appreciate the
answer it's very yeah it's like you're
ready for it
go do you know yeah and I it listen if
you do it
please check back in with me I would
love to hear that there's a plan on it
my only issue right now is that a lot of
the clubs in Indianapolis where I'm at
there's not as many as other places and
they require uh they require you to
bring a bunch of people which as I just
said that's kind of the issue yeah but
I'm gonna get started on it I appreciate
it I've watched like everything you've
done including the uh that rework
special you did of your earlier material
that got taken down or you took down
yeah I loved it but yeah I appreciate it
appreciate the answer
well it seemed like you I thought maybe
you wanted to continue to work on it
maybe it wasn't completely polished but
I still enjoyed it yeah no I took it
down because I want to re-record it
now that Cove is over in front of an
audience so I didn't even realize that
wow yeah that one was in front of like
25 people yeah it was just that that
makes sense it was just like I'd rather
record it in front of people it makes it
more enjoyable for the people watching
it
I was wondering why because I thought it
was good material I was pretty happy
with it I I know I love the material it
was 20 socially distanced masked people
yeah so it really is a smile yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's not I'm gonna re-record
but I appreciate you saying that man no
problem you guys have a good night thank
you
um you you can also pick
all right guys we're taking off here oh
we're past the hour mark why don't you
pick a question and then we'll
if you can't find streamers that just
take the shroom bar I gave you
oh yeah dude 100 don't worry oh yeah I'm
gonna that's probably what you're in for
that's right what's going on Scott
Michael
Scott Michael Christopher a three first
name dude [__] yeah yeah that is crazy
um all right do we see any more you want
to answer BV did you have a question you
want to ask
go ahead
hey nice meeting you guys and you guys
are awesome I'll tell you that right now
um real quick one was uh Jacob when
you're talking about smoking in school
and stuff like that we all did that the
thing that I got that was better than
most people was my art teacher was an
old hippie and she catches me one day
making a bunch of bongs for
putting the kiln and she's like Brian
what can you make with that I'm like
it's a or what can you call it instead
of what it is I'm like candle holder
he's like okay
the next the whole year I'm pumping out
bongs boom boom boom Oh it's like a like
a pottery class you were just making
that is were you making them and selling
them yep absolutely I wish I could help
is awesome I love that
the other thing real quick was on
business yeah it's for you Josh when you
had to stand in front of those people
that that girl that was kept puking in
that glass yeah could you smell that
no it's a really interesting I could not
smell it that's a great question if I
could have smelled it I'd have kicked
her out soon wait
I just had to ask that man that's yeah
that's a great question I never thought
about me either dude great question
um all right BV I appreciate you joining
us man thanks brother thank you take it
easy stay cool you guys are awesome
um it's a great question I never eat
that thought never even crossed my mind
yeah great beard is right right he did
have a great beer Michelle I do songs
every um
every show I'm writing more duets with
people
am I still friends with Chelsea hand
there I am
um
and so you have anything else you wanna
no I'm still uh oh worst heckler
I mean that would be for me right I want
to make sure that you
we've been to Maine yep we'll be back
please come uh Red Rocks we would I
would love to right we would love to
guys anybody anybody
is comedy what Jacob was looking to do
for a career I think we
there you go
are you happy
important thing I would have to ask
is that for both of us yeah you go first
I've never been happier in my life
I
am at a great Crossroads of knowing who
I am
um being comfortable with who I am
not trying to impress people anymore
and
just waking up and feeling
like there are some days where it
doesn't happen and you've got to get
yourself right
but feeling at peace with myself and not
allowing myself to go to Dark Places
that I used to allow myself to go to
uh giving my brain more credit
of being able to pull me back from
places like that
like if I start to drift I'll I am at a
point now where I can say I don't want
to do that anymore that's not who I am
and I I snap myself back so
I I've never had a better relationship
with my wife I feel like I've never had
a better relationship with all three of
my kids
and just having him on the road is
pretty amazing
so
I'm selling more tickets than I ever
have I feel like I'm a better comic than
I've ever been
um
I just I'm happy so for me yes
I would say for me yes as well you know
I just moved to Vegas I moved out of a
three bedroom apartment with my
girlfriend and we moved into a
three-bedroom house
um so that's pretty outstanding if you
would have told me the 26 that I'd be
living with my partner in a house not
owned but still just a house by
ourselves
I would tell you were crazy
um we have a dog together we have a
great life I have a a bright new career
path in front of me uh and the only
place to go is up
um like you said there are some days
that you wake up and you're just not
feeling it and for me as a younger kid
it's a little harder sometimes to get
out of those gray areas some days I'll
wake up and I just won't get out of bed
and you know for me like
for me it's okay that that stuff still
happens because you're okay to have
emotions it's okay to have emotions and
you're allowed to be able to be sad and
to work through it you know any way you
want to I mean I just work through it a
little different he works it works
through it by talking about it and going
out and doing stuff to take his mind off
of it I work through it by literally
sitting in it for a day and then I come
out of it so you know it not every day
is as as you know for me is as golden as
others but I would say overall yeah
that's awesome here
um a couple quick ones Kendra yeah I've
been to Spokane Comedy Club a bunch I go
every December we sell that place out
way ahead of time so if you do want to
go I would get tickets when they show up
uh Lennon I've been on kill Tony I'll go
back again I love Tony Hinchcliffe he's
a good dude uh Michelle thank you we
really do like to listen to each other
um and uh yeah
we'll be at Side Splitters in July by
the way
in Tampa oh oh yeah
um we would come to South Africa if they
booked us
uh uh let me why wouldn't we go it's not
safe really not safe at all especially
for people who look like you and me and
I never thought I'd say that out loud
really yeah dude not safe
like you know how like when white people
go to Mexico when they just get abducted
by the Mexican cartel for ransom and all
that yeah same thing in South Africa
what not safe not safe whatsoever hasn't
been for almost a decade I still want to
go you can go by yourself I will not be
going with you okay
um
okay just don't eat treats from your dad
it's a dog biscuit that's right
yeah I once he wants tried to hand me a
chocolate bar I was like what is this he
goes nothing and I'm looking at it and I
go is this a mushroom chocolate bar and
he was like yeah I tried to get you with
that no you can have it back he he won't
smoke weed with me but he'll do
mushrooms like let's do mushrooms
together I'm like one step at a time
dude like by the way this is what I
thought too South Africa is mostly White
that doesn't mean [__] by the way so
who's kidnapping it do you do your
research
I promise you I promise you I promise
you South Africa is not safe okay uh
well like just because it's mostly white
doesn't mean anything yeah I think it's
safe and I think it's safe and
out of South Africa
I would go anywhere guys to do stand-up
I truly would
um okay guys we gotta run oh wait a
second I do want to say yeah what's up
dude
what's up how you been can you hear me
how you been
yeah good how are y'all I'm doing well
thank you
what do you got there
it's a 500 million
oh [__]
that's pretty good
yeah
he's probably about to talk to the devil
doggy how you been you've been good
you've been getting on stage
I'm still writing but I haven't
performed in probably a year
I'm a little too uh melanin deficient
non-menstrating person that looks like
me is hard to get on in Charlotte
before let me tell you something dude
you're a good joke writer I know that to
be true
I didn't make a 60 bucks at a showcase I
opened the Showcase about 60 bucks for
six minutes not bad
um yeah dude bingo that's the one this
is what Jeff said thank you who cares
what color you are this kidnap I just
don't know why we're getting kidnapped
same reason that that people get
kidnapped in Mexico it's like a ransom
it's to make money to for anything
oh I'll have to Google that I'm telling
I've done enough research I promise you
um but Jeff correct I mean yeah this is
I'm not saying yeah okay
um but listen man I uh I hope you get
back on stage
yeah
um
and uh
I'd love to hear about it when you do
yeah man I'll send you some videos
[__] yeah you got anything you want to
ask or say
I'm good
all right cool I wanted I wanted to say
yeah I love your shirt let's say bacon
yeah enjoy bacon that's right who
doesn't
um all right my man
Josephus oh Josephus yeah
um
I would love to perform on the moon
uh all right everybody we gotta go we
gotta hit the gym it's 4 20. oh it's a
great note
7 15 show tonight oh it's all sold out
guys yeah 7 15 show tonight what time do
we get there we'll figure it out yeah we
wouldn't have to do it on there yeah
guys we love you thank you so much thank
you all for stopping by we appreciate it
um
anything else you want me to do the do
the things the plugs and then what not
yeah well I just want to address this
love your humor but gotta tell you
although we don't like all the weed
mushroom talk yeah not every stream is
like that and we answer questions that
people bring up
um why do you do so much to help feel
happy
I've gone large stretches of not doing
it and then I go stretches of doing it
but
I do it when it makes me feel good I I
like taking mushrooms it makes me feel
good I like smoking weed it makes me
feel good I if I were you Irena
um if you don't like to talk you're not
going to hurt my feelings by not
um watching and I guess it's a
legitimate question why do I do so much
to help me feel happy that's not why I
do it I just I like it
um yeah man I would just say you should
probably live your life and yeah I'll
take care of mine absolutely you know
what I mean
um I'd like to take some mushies tonight
before the show if I can find some
all right uh I'll do all the plugs uh
comedian joshua.com for tour dates
um and then Joshua comedy on all
platforms
um it's Jake wolf on Tick Tock Jake
underscore wolf on Instagram guys we do
a podcast that we release every week
called hey man
um it's free wherever you look for
podcasts Spotify Apple all that good
stuff Ray Ray is wearing one of our
t-shirts
um it's it's just us two we just it's
pretty much kind of like this except we
just kind of shoot the [__] and we talk
about anything from Sports to life to as
you heard about the little bit of drug
talk we had today where we want to
travel you know all the all the
miscellaneous things
um so that's wherever you can find
podcasts
um sometimes people ask what can we do
to help uh it's it's real easy I know
you guys listen to a lot of podcasts and
I know everybody says it but if you
could go and find us on wherever you do
it mostly iTunes on the Apple Store and
you go and find our podcast and you rate
it you follow it and you leave a comment
or a review it takes us takes us takes
us to the top so thank you guys again
um we couldn't do any of this without
you in the first place so thank you for
sticking with us
um
that's it that's it
head over to the podcast we really uh
enjoy doing it yeah we love you we'll be
filming another one tomorrow while we're
here in Royal Oak yeah um and you know
we can't wait for you guys to hear it
yeah and the membership starts uh we'll
do it in July remember to start YouTube
in July
um Jason there's your shout out man all
right everybody we love you Deuces later